-You know, Al, I'm so psyched
you're on the show.
Logan, welcome back to the show.
Al, we've never met.
-No.
-But people people have always
asked me to do
an impression of you,
and I don't really
have a great one.
No, I'm not gonna do it.
I promise.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's cool, it's cool.
-I don't have a great one of you
because I'm such
a fan of your work.
But your voice has changed
all throughout your career,
and you've done
different characters.
-Yes.
-Scarface and, you know,
"Scent of a Woman."
So I don't know which one to do,
so when I do an impression,
it's all confused,
and it sounds nothing like you.
-It's sort of a montage?
-Yeah, it's -- [ Laughs ]
Tony Montage is what I call it,
yeah.
Yeah.
I'm happy that you're here.
And, Logan,
I'm happy that you're back.
-I'm so happy to be here.
-Last time you were on the show,
I gave you a --
I give you a gift.
-A thermometer.
Your "SNL" thermometer.
It's like the prized possession
in my house.
I have it in my --
my -- my kitchen.
It's like the thing
I show people when they come in.
-I didn't believe this,
but then you brought a photo.
This is the thermometer
that I gave to you.
-Oh, yeah.
-From "Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah, it's right
on the cookbooks.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
-I'm very thankful
that you kept that.
-Are you kidding?
It was an honor.
I mean, that's so cool.
And not to mention,
I'm, like, a huge "SNL" fan.
So to have this piece of history
from "SNL," from you,
it just meant a lot.
I love it.
-Logan, you and Al have gotten
to know each other
doing this series together.
And Al invited you over
to a poker night
over at his --
-Yes. Poker.
-When was that?
[ Laughter ]
-Pre-pandemic.
It was before --
-Yeah, it was a while ago.
What is that like playing --
Are you a big poker player, Al?
-Well, I never thought I was,
but perhaps I am.
-Yeah, wow.
-Well, I was nervous, though,
to play with you 'cause
I thought you would be amazing,
and, like, all your friends
are incredible,
and I didn't really know
how to play.
-Oh, yeah, but you see,
the games that we used to have,
very low stakes, you know, so...
But they were because we had
all kinds of people in the game.
People who worked,
people who didn't.
So it was it was a very --
-It's just story time.
And, like, I just remember
there was, like,
a whole table of pastrami.
-Oh, pastrami.
-Pastrami and stories,
and that was it.
-I was like, "Okay.
It's a safe space.
We can play."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it was great.
-You have your old faction,
and you have your young faction.
-But do you have a thing?
Do you have --
Are you good bluffer?
Are you a good poker --
-No, I'm not.
I don't -- I don't --
You don't need to bluff when
it's so low, the stakes.
-Yeah.
-You just go in and go...
-Just go and just play.
-Yeah, you just play.
-Just play, yeah.
-Hang out.
-But I used to do
one thing there, I remember,
which people
will either find funny,
but the people who I was playing
with didn't find it funny,
but I found it funny because
there were a lot of old friends,
friends I've known
since I was a teenager,
actually, some of them.
And what I would do is,
in the middle of a game,
I just like play cards
because it's so much fun.
The games -- we used to mix up
the games, different games.
Yeah, we had Texas Hold'em,
you had Omaha
and all kinds of games.
So I would just get up
and go into my bathroom
because it's in my office
we would play,
and I'd look in the mirror
and there were the old guys
who've known me all my life,
and I just would...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
I would just yell out --
I would just yell out
as I looked in the mirror,
"I'm beautiful!"
[ Laughter ]
"Why didn't you tell me?!"
-[ Laughing ] What?
And I would think
they would hear it
in the other room, you know?
-Everyone's just confused, like,
"What is going on in there?"
-Except for Marty Bregman,
who is my producer
and knew me a long time,
he would say,
"He's being funny, you know?"
-Yeah. That's never good when
you have to explain to everyone
that you're being funny.
I love it.
"I'm beautiful.
Why didn't you tell me?"
-I'm so glad
you people are like it.
-Oh, yeah, I thought that was --
I'm gonna steal that bit.
I like it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna do it tonight.
-I have a couple of others.
-Yeah.
-Which I won't go into now,
but you probably --
we'll probably
get there somehow.
-I was reading about you,
and before you got into --
This is probably in the '60s,
your career took off.
You were writing sketch comedy
and doing...
-Actually, I was.
I was doing -- I had a partner
who has since gone,
but when we were young --
we were like 19, 20 years old --
we would get together
and do these skits together,
and I guess they were
a way of just --
And then we went further,
and we were, like, partners,
but Second City,
he went with Second City
way back then.
He was quite good.
And Brucie Cohen. He's gone,
but he was quite good.
And I remained --
I liked doing him
because, you know,
I was always so depressed
that, by getting up
and bringing it out like that,
I'd feel much better.
-Just make people laugh, yeah.
-And it was nice
to have an audience,
a live audience.
That's why I always keep
coming back to the theater.
If you know
a little bit about me, I do --
I do movies, and I do theater.
-Yeah.
-And because --
I have a story from that.
I was trying
to move this to that
because I got a nice story.
-Please.
-Yeah.
-We all want to hear it.
-I don't know
if you've heard this.
I know --
I know Jimmy hasn't,
and I don't think
any of you have, really.
Well, I was a young actor
working in Boston,
and I -- and I was in this play,
"The Basic Training
of Pavlo Hummel,"
if you've ever heard of it.
-Yes.
-David Rabe
is a great playwright.
and we were in
Boston performing,
and I remember
it was a long play,
and I had the lead in it,
and I was playing the play,
and I was out there for a while.
And then I noticed
that one part of the audience,
as though
I was looking out here,
you know,
I was playing the part,
but I was feeling someone's
eyes, like, riveted on me.
And it was the first time
that ever happened to me.
So I was just, like, stunned,
and I thought, "What is this?"
And I started doing
the performance
for that part of the audience,
and I just kept going
and doing it.
And I thought, "Oh, wow.
I've got to see these eyes,"
you know?
And I --
You felt --
You felt a connection.
Yeah. This is too much.
A huge connection.
It was, like, overpowering me.
I mean, it was so steady.
So I thought,
finally curtain call comes,
so I'm gonna come out,
and I am gonna look over
in that corner.
So curtain call comes,
and I go out,
and that's the first thing I do.
I go right to that corner,
and I see that there's
two seeing-eye dogs
right in the audience.
[ Laughter ]
That's a -- that's a fact.
-Wow.
-That's a true story.
-You felt the connection.
-I felt that --
Well, they're so riveted,
you know?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Part of their thing, you know?
That's what they do.
And it was amazing to me.
-Yeah.
-And then I thought,
"That's what theater is."
You know, that's theater.
-The mystique.
-Yeah.
A lot of things happen.
-Let's talk about the second
and final season of "Hunters."
Logan, you signed on to do this
show before Al was attached.
How does it feel to have
your co-star be Al Pacino?
-Oh, my God.
Can you --
I mean, come on.
It's incredible.
It's, like, the greatest
that's ever done it.
The best actor ever.
And I just was so excited
when I found out.
And to be able to spend
so much time with you,
it's been one of the greatest
joys,
experiences, everything,
in my life.
I learned so much,
and I love you so much.
But as you could see,
I mean, there's -- your trove
of incredible stories.
And I just -- I can sit and talk
with you for hours and hours.
-He asked me
about coming on the show.
I said, "Well, you know,
I've been around for a while,
so I got a lot of go-tos."
You know, you come up with the
audience, come up with anything,
and I'll just --
No, don't.
[ Laughter ]
But anything.
I got a story for everything.
-Logan, you got -- you shot this
show, the series, in Prague.
And when you were there,
there was another star
staying at your hotel,
and I was just wondering
if you could tell that story.
-Oh, yeah, sure.
I'm like,
"Why does anybody
want to hear a story from me?
Turn off my mic.
I want to --"
-Oh, no!
-I'm sitting here,
I'm captivated.
I want to hear you.
Yeah, we were
shooting in Prague,
and they had another production.
This is so funny.
Like, my story is, like,
so not as interesting.
But Chris Hemsworth was
staying there, and he's filming.
-Who's he?
-He's an actor.
He's like a guy, a big guy.
-I know, I know.
-Big swollen dude.
But, basically, they're doing
like "Extraction 2,"
and we're filming out there.
This is an action show,
so you have to do -- you know,
to continue working out
and things like that.
So I'd always go to the gym,
and I'd be stuck,
just me and Chris Hemsworth.
And there's nothing
more emasculating
than working out
next to Chris Hemsworth.
-He's -- He's --
Yeah, he's built, he's built.
-And mind you, mind you,
he has no idea who I am.
And we're down there often,
and we start talking.
And for some reason he thought
I was a stunt guy on his movie.
And so --
-But here's the best part.
-I never -- I never told him
that I wasn't,
so I just, like, told -- like,
pretended like I was just
the stunt guy,
you know, on his film, like,
showing up every day.
I'm like,
"Yeah, work was crazy yesterday
in the prison set.
Yeah, for sure. Definitely.
I know what you mean.
-To this day, does he know...?
-He probably doesn't know
who I am.
He has no idea.
[ Laughter ]
-Chris, if you're watching,
this is Logan Lerman.
A very talented actor.
You're gonna like his stuff.
-In Prague.
-He's a very talented actor.
-But that was a funny --
funny little thing happened
when we were
filming the second season.
-Logan, can you set up
what "Hunters" --
What's going on
this final season?
-Oh, well, yeah,
this final season,
it plays on the conspiracy that
Hitler survived World War II
and that he was actually
living in South America.
And so our team of hunters
are gathering,
you know,
are getting back together
to try to track him down
in South America somewhere
and bring him to justice.
-Here's Al Pacino
and Logan Lerman
in season one finale
of "Hunters."
Take a look.
-Who am I?
If I don't do this --
if I don't do this, who am I?
Who?
-You're a boy.
That's who you are.
You didn't even
bring me The Wolf.
You brought me a [bleep]...
-I [bleep] found you.
I found you.
-Jonah, don't let this man
destroy your life, too.
-What are you gonna do?
-You destroyed my [bleep] world.
-I destroyed your world?
There's a [bleep] kid
running around the streets.
I gave you the world.
What are you doing?
You're gonna do something
with that?
-Jonah, he wants you to kill.
Don't give him what he wants.
-You think I want to live?
Go ahead.
Only the hunt lives.
♪♪
-Jonah, no, pease.
-Do you understand?
Only the hunt.
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
-You know there'll be
another time for you to do this.
You can't do
what you think is necessary.
-Amen.
[ Gunshot ]
-Aah!
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Al Pacino and Logan Lerman,
everybody!
"Hunters," season two,
begins streaming
on Prime Video this Friday.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."